THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT."
♪ ♪
>> Bret: A GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
WE ARE JUST FOUR DAYS FROM
TUESDAY'S CRUCIAL MIDTERM
ELECTION, ARE TO BELIEVE, FOR
DAYS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS RIGHT NOW
HALFWAY THROUGH A CAMPAIGN
DOUBLEHEADER ON THIS FINAL
FRIDAY.
IN ADDITION TO DUMPING FOUR
CANDIDATES, HE'S CONTINUING HIS
HARD SELL ON THE SIGNATURE ISSUE
FOR THIS POLITICAL SEASON,
IMMIGRATION AND BORDER SECURITY.
HE'S ALSO WRITING A POSITIVE
WAVE OF ECONOMIC NEWS IN THE
FINAL DAYS OF THIS CAMPAIGN.
CHIEF CORRESPONDENT JOHN ROBERTS
ARTS IS OFF TONIGHT AS HE    HEO
ARTS IS OFF TONIGHT AS HE    HET
ARTS IS OFF TONIGHT AS HE    HEN
DOES.
EVEN CRITICS ARE SAYING THIS IS
A STELLAR JOBS REPORT.
>> NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
BACK IN 1992, BILL CLINTON WON
THE PRESIDENCY ON THE MANTRA
THAT THE ECONOMY WAS STUPID.
IN FACT AND THE ECONOMY WAS A
BAD NEWS STORY AND TODAY IT'S A
GOOD NEWS STORY.
DOES GOOD NEWS MOTIVATE VOTERS
TO THE POLLS ON THE SAME WITHOUT
BAD NEWS DOES?
PRESIDENT TRUMP CERTAINLY HOPE
SO.
>> President Trump: THE
NUMBERS ARE ABOUT AS GOOD AS YOU
WILL EVER SEE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP DEPARTED THE
WHITE HOUSE FOR CAMPAIGN RALLIES
IN WEST VIRGINIA AND INDIANA
WITH ANOTHER ISSUE TO TAKE TO
VOTERS, ANOTHER MONTH OF STRONG
JOB CREATION AND THE LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT.
>> I THINK IT MAY BE THE
GREATEST ECONOMY THAT OUR
COUNTRY HAS EVER HAD AND I HOPE
PEOPLE REALIZE THAT WHEN THEY GO
OUT ON TUESDAY AND THEY VOTE OR,
THEY DO EARLY VOTING.
BUT I HOPE PEOPLE REALIZE THAT.
>> HE ALSO KEPT UP THE DRUMBEAT
ON ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AT HIS
FIRST STOP, INSISTING NOTHING
LESS THAN AMERICA'S SOVEREIGNTY
IS AT STAKE.
>> President Trump: CARAVAN
AFTER CARAVAN IS FORMING,
UNVENTED ILLEGAL ALIENS TRYING
TO FLOOD INTO OUR COUNTRY ON
YOUR DOLLAR, OVERWHELMING OUR
SCHOOLS, DEPLETING OUR RESOURCE
RESOURCES, AND ENDANGERING YOUR
COMMUNITY.
>> THE MIGRANT CARAVANS ARE
NOWHERE NEAR THE UNITED STATES,
YET TODAY A DOZEN HONDURANS IN
THE CARAVAN SUED PRESIDENT TRUMP
FOR DENYING THEM THEIR FIFTH
AMENDMENT RIGHTS TO DUE PROCESS
SAYING THEY HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO REQUEST
REQUIREMENT
ASYLUM.
ASKED ABOUT THE LAWSUIT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP TURNED HIS FIRE
ON THE HONDURAN GOVERNMENT.
>> President Trump: THEY LET
PEOPLE COME UP AND FORM THEIR
CARAVANS IN THE COUNTRY.
THEY ARE DOING NOTHING.
WE ARE PAYING THEM HUNDREDS OF
THAT MONEY WILL STOP SOON.
>> THE PRESIDENT ALSO CLARIFIED
A STATEMENT THAT WILL RAISE
EYEBROWS YESTERDAY BUT SEEM TO
SUGGEST THE U.S. MILITARY MIGHT
USE LETHAL FORCE OF THE MIGRANTS
TRY TO FORCE THEIR WAY ACROSS
THE BORDER.
>> President Trump: THEY WANT
TO THROW ROCKS AT OUR MILITARY,
OUR MILITARIES FIGHTS BACK.
I TOLD THEM TO CONSIDER IT A
RIFLE.
>> HE SAID TODAY IT'S NOT HIS
INTENTION TO HAVE ANYONE
SHOOTING ANYONE.
>> President Trump: NO, NO NO
NO.
BUT IF OUR SOLDIERS OR BORDER
PATROL OR I.C.E. ARE GOING TO BE
HIT IN THE FACE WITH ROCKS, WE
WILL ARREST THOSE PEOPLE.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN SHOOT THEM,
BUT WE WILL ARREST THOSE PEOPLE
QUICKLY AND FOR A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME.
>> THERE ALSO APPEARED TO BE
SOME MOVEMENT ON THE CHINA ISSUE
TODAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CONFIRMING THAT
HE WILL MEET WITH PRESIDENT XI
AT THE G20 IN BUENOS AIRES LATER
THIS MONTH INDICATING THAT CHINA
WILL BE CHOOSING THE TRADE.
>> AS YOU KNOW THEIR ECONOMY
WENT WAY DOWN SINCE WE HAVE BEEN
DOING THE SKIRMISH.
I SPOKE WITH PRESIDENT XI
YESTERDAY AND THEY VERY MUCH
WANT TO MAKE THE DEAL.
>> WHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY
OF MAKING A NEW TRADE DEAL WITH
CHINA, HE'S ALSO PREPARED TO
TAKE A BASEBALL BAT TO THEM,